bueno ahora vamos a restar números
complejos tengo el número complejo que 6
2 y y tengo el número complejo b que es
2 - y aquí ya hice el diagrama de around
correspondiente los números complejos
están representados como vectores en el
plano cartesiano con ejes es imaginario
y eje real pero bueno supongamos que
ahora quiero definir un número complejo
sé que va a estar o que va a ser igual a
la diferencia entre a y b
- b entonces como podría ser esto pues a
a vale 6 2 y 6 2
y b cuánto vale pues b vale
2 - y así que es menos 2 - sí
para hacer esta diferencia para obtener
esa resta lo que puedo hacer es 6 menos
2 y no lo puedo manipular recuerden no
puedo sumar partes reales con partes
imaginarias pero aquí lo que podría ser
es distribuir este menos pensar esto
como más menos por 2 es menos 2 menos
uno por 12 menos 2 - 1 por menos y sería
más y
de modo que ahora esto es una suma y
esto ya lo sé hacer cuánto me da esto
pues lo que tengo que hacer es sumar la
parte real de este número con la parte
real de este otro número 6 más menos 2
sería 4 4 y ahora tengo que sumar la
parte imaginaria con la parte imaginaria
2 más 1
estrés así que sería más 3 y luego la
que tengo heredada de estasis así que
sumó parte real con parte real parte
imaginaria comparte imaginaria y me da 4
más 13 pero como lo podría ver
gráficamente cómo hacer relación a eso
con los diagramas de argán pues veamos
lo que voy a hacer es decir a pues a
menos b es lo mismo que a más
v
a más de que fue implícitamente el truco
que usé aquí abajo y si lo hago así
entonces tienes menos ve pues y ve es
igual a 2 menos y entonces menos b
simplemente multiplico todo por menos y
obtengo menos dos más y y gráficamente
como se ve eso cuál sería el vector que
le correspondería pues sería menos 2 más
y así que bueno aquí quizás no se vea
porque lo hice un poco chueco pero el
chiste es que simplemente refleje al
vector b alrededor del origen así que
esto sería menos b y ahora sí cuánto es
más menos b pues tomo este vector que
está anclado al origen y lo copio pero
tomando como punto inicial ahora el
final de a la cabeza de a y entonces
sería dos unidades hacia acá y luego uno
unido hacia arriba
entonces más o menos
más o menos esto sería una copia del
vector b
una copia del vector b
del vector menos b perdón esto sería una
copia del vector menos d
y entonces cuál es mi vector resultante
pues con qué color lo hacemos vamos a
hacerlo con azul cielo por un lado había
dicho que era 4 + 3
y mi vector resultantes y nuestros
vectores sería este vector de aquí
y ese vector de ahí que no tienen tiene
parte real
y parte imaginaria
3 así que estas dos naciones coinciden
en la noción de la diferencia de dos
números complejos como su diferencia
como vectores en un diagrama de arganda
y la diferencia algebraica que sólo
obtuve manipulando y distribuyendo este
signo menos sobre este 2 y sobre menos y
este menos multiplicó a 2 menos y con
este truquito se corresponde la
diferencia de números complejos con la
diferencia de vectores en un diagrama de
arganda y además eso me permite definir
la diferencia de dos números complejos
como la diferencia de sus partes reales
y partes imaginarias respectivamente